well let's talk about the show because
there's so much going on
i want to start with joe and jackson
okay
what was your reaction when you first
heard about
this storyline well i first heard about
it
um right before we actually shut down
and then the storyline got tweaked just
a little bit to be
a covert sex pod is what i'm calling it
yeah but i
was really shocked but um
excited at the same time first off i do
love working with dusty williams we
always have
ask for scenes together because we have
a lot of fun we have a lot of fun
between takes together it's just really
we enjoy it
um so i was excited to do the scenes but
i was also excited to see a single
joe this season and and to see
what she looks like as a woman out there
in the world
dating sure do you think
she is still in love with
career or part of her will always be
that's a really interesting question i
think
at this point i don't think she's in
love with him anymore
that's that would be my guess is that
she's not in love with him anymore
but that she was in love with
the life they had and the idea of the
future they had together and i think
that might be more painful to let go of
for her sure
well i think it's not the person anymore
i think it's what they had
i mean with jackson she did try
to hook up with him initially and it
didn't work out i think because she was
kind of
trying to figure out what is single joe
like yeah
like sanskrit yeah i think that even if
you're not in love with someone like
that first
kiss of kissing somebody after you've
kissed someone for so long is so strange
and jarring
probably brings up a bunch of stuff
that's what i felt like she was feeling
i think that it was just a lot of
feelings at once
and then she was ready what do you think
it was about that second
time i mean you said all of a sudden she
was ready do you think anything shifted
emotionally for her do you think she
gave herself a pep talk in a way
i think that she wasn't drinking vodka
from
a bottle which helped i think
there was no pressure i think that she
put pressure on herself
and there wasn't any and and um
and sometimes like and it wasn't a date
situation whatsoever there wasn't like
you know
the jackson playing kenny g right
um so i exactly so i think with like the
pressure off
she realized in that moment like oh
actually i'm ready and just yeah
both of them said they do not want a
relationship
this is just a quarantine hookup do you
believe that
um yes and no i mean i don't believe it
because it's grey's anatomy and like
you know this is what happens but
playing her right now i believe that she
believes it
that's what i think and right now that
is what is happening in
our season but we haven't i haven't seen
this half of the season that i haven't
read so it could change
but um right now yeah what would it look
like if they were to
enter into a relationship
um you know what i actually think that
they would be a really
fun couple i think that they would have
that like banter back and forth of sort
of making fun of each other which you
will see
in the episode we're about to shoot
right now actually we're shooting next
week
you kind of see that happening between
them already so i think that they would
be that like very jokey couple with each
other
and hopefully i also think that
because they've had things have already
happened between them that are very
intimate and vulnerable i think
hopefully that they would
be open with talking about their
feelings because
they already had a conversation that was
pretty awkward to have at the door where
he was like i'm not ready
and she explained why and she said the
same thing and explained why too
um so yeah would you like it
to turn more serious i have
mixed opinions on it
yes because i love working with jessie
and yes because i think
jack's name is a good guy but i also
want to see her play the field a little
bit
ah do you think she used her eye on any
other
i don't think there is anybody else it's
covered and there's no options um
but i would like to sort of see more of
what
single joe is like okay
i was gonna ask you i mean she was in
such
a dark place after karev left and i feel
like last season in general she was in a
pretty dark place
yeah do you think now is kind of the
start
of a new beginning a new chapter
for joe and like there's light at the
end of the tunnel for her i definitely
do
i definitely do and it's interesting you
say that because i think that
it's more i'm going to be very cryptic
about it because i can't spoil anything
but there are a lot of elements of her
life that she's sort of reassessing
this season and thinking does this make
me happy
does this not make me happy what can i
do
to change it is she questioning her
career path maybe you'll have to watch
i will not say anything else but
there are other things she she kind of
questions and i think you know joe and
kovan you have a
lot of time to sit and think i think she
has a lot of time to sit and think and
sort of
really reassess everything what are the
chances karev
could return can we please not have
another ex-husband
for joe show up this poor girl
i just feel like how many are there
i mean do you think it would
help to give her closure though if he
did come back for some
reason i think the reality is for a lot
of people is that they don't get that
moment when they like
are speaking to their ex so i think it's
real to show that sometimes you have to
move on
without having the sit-down conversation
and so i think that she is she talks
about being in therapy
i actually like that she's able to work
through it
and it doesn't depend on whether he
picks up the phone and calls her and
wants to discuss it
i think it's like a very empowering
storyline for her